ladies and gentlemen four-time Academy
Award nominee Kate Winslet
as long as we're talking about motion
pictures let's say a few words about the
people who actually capture the motion
in pictures the cinematographers long
before they become members of the
Academy they have to understand a great
many things like optics chemistry lights
and shadows and most importantly where
to put the camera here are the nominees
Robert Richardson for The Aviator Josh
adding for House of Flying Daggers Caleb
Deschanel for The Passion of the Christ
John Matheson for The Phantom of the
Opera
Bruno del Bunnell for a very long
engagement
and the Oscar goes to Robert Richardson
the second oscar and fifth nomination
for robert richardson he took home his
first Oscar in this category for JFK
well I get to there um I'd like to say
thank you very much this evening for me
is dedicated to my mother who has spent
the last 45 days in the hospital and I'd
like to say thank you to all the nurses
and the doctors that have taken care of
her as well as her friends I love you
mom thank you
just ahead Salma Hayek Penelope Cruz and
the forth oscar-nominated song when the
77th annual Academy Awards return
you